last time i didn't join with audio i
should not have don't join with audio
good morning michael good morning
representative hatch
how are you i'm awesome
at least that's what lynn says but other
than that i'm fine
meaning i hope you have a good session
i'm gonna make myself invisible now
good morning
[Music]
wow
bill i wasn't ignoring you we
had a little technical problem
scott do we have any do we have any back
um
muted
is that better yeah all right it's
five past nine apologize for the delay
technology is
always great but we always have a few
little glitches
we are here in room 202 in the lob
i have a script that i am required by
the executive order to read when we
start
the meeting as chair of division one i
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public meeting pertaining to
division or
budget matters please note that there is
no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should email ledge
underscore fiscal at ledge.state.enh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled lba staff are
on the meeting
assisting us please note that all votes
taken during this meeting shall be roll
call votes
this requires a roll call call to start
the meeting
and i can tell you that i am here in
room 202
to my left his vice chairman tracy
emerick also here in room 202
to my right is representative robert
tuberge in room 202
and next to him is representative jerry
griffin
also in room 202. i'd like to call
bill hatch where are you sir i'm uh
good morning madam chair i'm at my home
in gorham and i'm
in my basement and my bride is somewhere
in the house
okay good morning mary beth we're doing
represent walls i am present
and i am alone in this part of the house
excellent this morning the first
agency we're going to hear from is the
public employees
labor relation board and with us we have
doug ingersoll
doug welcome to us and can you tell us
because i haven't looked what paid your
budget's on or do you want me to look
that up
328 ah but page 328
people who are watching at home watching
with us glad you had that page reference
i have a different one on my version i
okay welcome i know i sent you some
questions and
this is really for you to tell us about
your budget
what you have and welcome to division
one
thank you madam chair good morning uh
thank you for taking the time to review
our budget
and listen to my very brief presentation
my name is doug ingersoll
i'm the executive director and legal
counsel for the public employee labor
relations board i've held that position
for 10 years
and prior to that i was a staff attorney
with the pe lrb pelrb as you may know
is responsible for administering the
state's public sector collective
bargaining laws we have
four full-time employees one other
including myself
one other staff attorney and two support
staff
we are authorized to have a nine-member
board
it's essentially a volunteer board
members are appointed
for staggered six-year terms by governor
and council we currently have
uh six members on the board
two management representatives two labor
representatives
and two chairs so we have
enough board members to put together a
quorum to
review cases as necessary and to make
sure we can staff
cases if a particular member has a
conflict
i did answer the questionnaire i've
circulated it
our answers were pretty straightforward
essentially negative
in response to most of those i'll circle
back to that
and answer any questions you might have
about that
i also uh circulated a handout which is
just a little more detail about what we
do an organizational chart
a comparison of the fiscal year 2223
governor's budget to 20 and 21
and a little more detail about our
operations um
so let me just give you my overview from
a very high level
uh essentially we did work with the
governor's office
beginning in the summer
obviously it was a very challenging time
and
i would say the governor's budget
director was focused more on
some of the larger departments obviously
our percentage of the
overall general fund state budget is
relatively minor but
we did have back and forth with the
governor's budget director at the time
and i shared a lot of detail
about our operations and what we do and
it was my formal position that
operate as a functional board if there
were any
any significant reductions to our
general fund budget
any changes to our position
funding and ultimately the governor's
budget director
agreed with that and essentially adopted
the budget that we had submitted as part
of the
department budget phase
and the budget that that has actually
been submitted by the governor
closely tracks what we originally worked
on over the summer
in terms of comparison to prior years um
i think overall for the biennium
that there is an increase to general
funds of
approximately thirty five thousand
dollars um
that's attributable to an 11 000
increase scheduled in fiscal year 23 for
class
10 personal services
and class 60 benefits 10 000
increase in fiscal year 22
compared to authorized fiscal year 21
and fiscal year 23 17 286 increase and
class 60 benefits compared to fiscal
year
21. it's been my experience that our
class
60 benefits budget tends to be a little
high
and i know it's a little bit of a moving
target but
it's it's likely that the actual
expenditures in that class will be lower
and so our overall increase for the
biennium will probably be
less than the 35 thousand dollars i
mentioned
there are some other minor increases
so for example we are coming up to the
final year of a five-year lease
so starting this fall i will go through
the rfp process
and we have a little extra money in our
rents
uh class line to
address that anticipated rent increase
if it materializes and i think that's
per fiscal year um
what else fiscal year 27 oit
um after class 27 fiscal year 22
we uh scheduled to
replace a switch that we uh we have in
our i.t closet currently we're using a
loaner provided by oit
and unfortunately the cost for the
switch is 3500
so for that reason our class 27 budget
is higher uh compared to
fiscal year 21 but fiscal year
23 once that expense has been met that
number actually will be lower compared
that's pretty much that's pretty much
the high level
of view of the budget i'm happy to
answer any particular questions you may
have online items
um yes man i'm sure i'm just trying to
find out if the paperwork that our
witness is test
or referencing if that was sent out
electronically because
i i think that lba is posting as we go
along
mrs levines has been without electricity
much of the night and in the morning
although i see her
that she has managed to get here so mr
hoffman was
working by himself for a while due to
electrical problems
it looks like nancy is back so you'll be
able to see that on the lba website as
before
thank you it's going to say our power
went on at 10 30 and came back at 6am so
i can relate
oh boy well we have a generator so i
shouldn't complain but i did notice that
we were almost the only ones that had
power
yeah we have a generator as well okay
um yeah
representative emerick moves to approve
the budget
representative griffin seconds a motion
representative taberge do you have a
sir
okay then on the motion of
approving the budget representative
yes
think you're muted i i can't hear
anything
i didn't have it i'm sorry
representative representative hatch your
vote
yay mary beth
your vote representative waltz yes okay
thank you motion passes 601
with representative leishman absent mr
ingrassal thank you for coming and
spending the morning with us
madam chair i know representative
leishman was planning on being there in
person
i expect he'll be there soon yeah i
imagine he is
he may have been without electricity as
well yeah i saw on the news peterborough
was hit
so yeah you have to live for it's rough
we have power
well i have a generator too but we had
we it's my understanding that hb2 was
released to the governor
by ols yesterday for a last
look at the bill just as any of us when
we file a bill
gets the bill before it's released to
the public i am expecting
that it will be released to us today
if so tomorrow morning at nine o'clock
we will be reviewing our sections of hb2
kind of in generality to give us a good
overview this is 167 pages
and some of the things that if you've
read hb2 already because we have had the
draft
we are the last i think the department
of energy starts something like
section 84 85 and runs through section
it's many pages oplc
who will be here on thursday is much the
same we've asked them to come prepared
to talk to it
but i thought if we had any questions it
would be good to ask lba
our questions and give them a little
chance before some of our agencies get
here with the bigger ones
we will have at 9 30 the department of
labor
so i'm going to ask tracy to
mute us and ask all of you to mute
yourselves
mr hoffman
and over 5000 elevator inspections
the division is also proactive training
approximately 2500 employers per year on
employment law
to assist businesses with compliance uh
2020 of course being an exception
as the public health emergency forced
cancellation
of in-person training last spring
the division did develop and conduct
remote electronic training
and will continue to offer this service
in the future to employers
among other duties the worker
compensation division
collects first reports of injury from
employers and insurance carriers in new
hampshire
regarding roughly 30 to 40 000
workplace injuries per year conducts
over
1500 formal hearings per year and
manages
non-appropriated revolving trust fund
collections
and payments approaching 20 million
dollars per year
which is if you've looked at our budget
in total
uh that's nearly double the size of the
entire
the entire operating budget of the
department
uh while the department's total
appropriations are funded 100 percent by
agency income that revenue is derived
through two
distinct sources the administration fund
and the restricted fund the
administration fund is described in rsa
281 a
colon 59 it comes from a pro rata
assessment of the department's annual
budget for work
compensation related activities
and it's levied on the worker
compensation insurance carriers and
self-insured
entities in the state the restricted
fund
on the other hand is described in rsa
1b and it comes from the sum of all
other
fees licenses certificates and civil
penalties
of the department the balance
remaining in the restricted fund is
transferred to the general fund at the
conclusion
of each year after our non-worker comp
uh operating car costs are paid
so we are a general fund contributor
two years ago the labor department
documented
and wrote a new cost allocation plan
so that the burden on either of those
funding sources the administration fund
or the restricted fund
can actually be traced to measurable
statistics from our operation
we believe that we've continued to
improve on that model
in this new budget request a number of
expenses that were
budgeted in each division have been
centralized in the administration
division
which is already funded by a statistical
allocation method
we believe that this approach will will
do several things
facilitate business office functions
reduce
duplicative purchasing by the divisions
and also generate
additional dollars for our general fund
contribution at the end of the year the
governor's office provided us an overall
expense target
of 9.5 million dollars in year one
that represented a 10 percent decrease
from our
2021 adjusted authorized the
adjusted year 2 target was also about
000 lower than our current operating
budget
and we met both of those targets with
our efficiency budget request
if you look at department-wide class
lines
these uh reductions have impacted four
classes
most profoundly salaries benefits
doit transfers and post retirement
benefits
in addition to our decision to add no
new positions
in 22 or 23 we have also defunded
18 out of our 92 full-time classified
positions
in order to make efficiency target
while this does remove significant
staffing flexibility the department
has been operating for many years with a
20 percent vacancy rate
and we'll be able to operate we believe
normally
doit staffing has also been reduced from
five full-time direct staff to two
full-time direct staff one position uh
has been restored in the governor's
recommended budget
as we're one full-time and one part-time
doit
staff we are in the process of launching
our new on-base
document management system this spring
and expect to realize some operational
improvements as a result
what we need really in the new biennium
rather than deeper staffing
is operational flexibility and have
attempted to provide for this through
better funding of some of the
operational class lines
the governor has also included a
significant
prioritized needs for technology funding
and this is to allow us to migrate off
of what i'm i'm told is the state's
last remaining as400 ibm mainframe
and before i conclude one other note
that we wanted to make
because we we have a correction that we
would like to ask for
the funding mix the revenue mix
in accounting unit 6000
went astray somehow in the governor's
recommended budget
if we could reduce 6000
class 6 revenue by
thirty 48 dollars are you on ken uh
335 yep okay
so if you see the the agency income
classes at the bottom
class six and class nine yep those are
those are what i'm referring to so let's
see
uh yes uh
class six in year one
we'd like to reduce that by forty eight
thousand five thirty seven
and then reduce the same class by forty
five thousand
eight seventeen in year two
and then increase accounting unit 6000
class 9 by the same figures in each year
we we believe that the state
would benefit by roughly a hundred
thousand dollars over the biennium by
having the correct fund mix in that
accounting unit have you submitted that
to us in paper
we we have not will you please
sure thank you absolutely
and um that concludes my remarks
representative over so i'm happy to take
questions
we have a draft copy of hb2 and you have
quite a large
section in there um are you prepared to
talk about that today or do you want to
come back
no uh we can talk about that we know
what we submitted to the governor's
office we haven't seen what was
you haven't seen it all right um then i
guess we'll have to have you come back
hb2 is my understanding was sent back to
the governor's office sometime yesterday
which is um normal
procedure with all laws the person who
puts it in
gets a chance to review it and
before it becomes public we are
expecting it to become public
and although we have draft copies since
you haven't seen it
in fairness to you we'll ask you to come
back i'll just schedule some time
i don't think it'll take a long time to
go over it but it did seem to be
rather lengthy so we would like your
input on that
sure happy to do it tell me about the
reduction in class 27
how did that get reduced yeah
um significant staffing reductions
i i might have mentioned uh that there
were
five full-time positions budgeted
in the doit budget and we currently
have two uh staff members
so those other three positions were
reduced
but we did get one back in the
governor's recommended as a
so you believe in that area you came out
okay
because i saw that you said all your
prioritized needs were
funded yes okay yes i did not
i'm sorry i just to add to that um we
had already determined
that uh we were going to reduce the
number of positions
uh in doit that were that were embedded
here as direct
positions okay questions from
yes uh commissioner maryfield if you
were to be
level funded with the prior biennium how
much
more money would need to go to labor to
be level funded
level funding in the efficiency budget
in the overall and the entire budget if
department of labor were to receive the
same amount of money it received in the
prior budget
what's the difference how much more
would it be for it to be level funding
between the two budgets
i think my immediate guess is it's about
a half a million dollars
uh let me see if i can
so total governor budget 10.1 yeah
it's just about a half a million dollars
okay i'm not talking from the governor's
budget i'm talking from the budget past
two years ago
right okay just make now it's clear
okay and are you referring to efficiency
budget
then i'm referring to the budget that
we're being asked to approve today
in comparison with the budget we
approved two years ago absolutely so
that is the governor's recommended
budget
okay okay so uh roughly
forgive me half a million dollars thank
you
any additional questions for mr
marinfield
seeing none thank you for spending
some time with us this morning and when
hb2 is released we will schedule you to
come back for a short amount of time to
talk about
your section in hb2 sure my
my pleasure thank you thank you
mr hoffman we are again running ahead
we're going to be in recess for 10
minutes so we are all going to mute
ourselves
and we'll be back at 10 o'clock
hopefully there are no more electrical
gremlins that show up
we have with us the agricultural
commissioner
mr jasper do you have some handouts for
us someplace
uh i was not asked to
provide anything yeah you got a letter
from me
that said please provide handouts in
hard copy and bring them with you and
also digitally so that the people at
home can
see it because lba is putting that up on
the screen
i'm i'm afraid we didn't see that as a
matter of fact
i only learned that we were on
today when i was going through the
calendar uh last friday
so i think there's been some yeah janet
confirmed this with your office i don't
know who's doing that for you
last week before it came up in the
calendar okay
so your budget is on page 231
we will start we will go through it line
by line and we will ask some questions
as we go along
so at the bottom of page 231 you start
with your
class 10 which is going down can you
explain that to us
what we have have done in order to meet
the governor's
uh target is we have
we have two two funds
the primarily the scale
and product testing fund and
we have traditionally bought uh
equipment
primarily cars out of that uh our
fleet's in
in good shape and so we have shifted in
that area
um
[Music]
more personnel into that account and not
purchasing um
vehicles we may have one or two in there
but we've reduced that
then the other fund that we have is so
commissioner if i could yes
four 4 dollars and that's because you
shifted a person out for part of a year
i'm i'm sorry maybe um
michelle should be on and i don't know
if she can be
brought on she'll sure she can if she's
up here yeah
michelle thibodeaux yes
michelle did you hear the question about
the class class
10 it's down just four thousand dollars
from that and i don't have that detail
yes
well she's looking for that though that
primarily we have done
a lot of shifting around and we have
that one change that we're asking for
to rsa 4 30 50.
integrated pest management and this is
how
we are managing our budget without doing
any layoffs
foreign
commissioner maybe while she's looking
we can go to class 11.
um that went up and i assume that is
your salary went up from 109
474 to 114
391 and then it jumps again
in 2023 to 122 336.
can you talk about those increases um
yeah i mean that would be primarily my
my salary
um and uh because
obviously commissioners aren't on a
scale and that probably brings me
to the to the top of the scale in the
final the final
year current expenses went up i'm now
on class 20 while michelle works out
what how did what i mean that jumped
five-fold
what's going on there
um i'm afraid again
that level of detail is something
michelle has
um michelle do you know the answer to
that one
i'm sorry i didn't catch that one class
increased from two thousand nine hundred
dollars to ten thousand three hundred
i am i'm s i have to apologize i am
looking
at a different budget so i'm not on the
same pages
as you i apologize i'm trying to pull it
up through
the computer system and it's not
cooperating with me
oh
my pages are marked differently from
yours
you know we have the budget book so we
have you on page 231
now
most of our um class
20 expenditures though we are
trying to put more of it under
putting transfers from other agencies
our department
would have just one class trying to have
one class
20 fund under the commissioner and the
account to pay those expenses i do see
your au 2133 division weights and
measures
dropped 7 900
so you think that was just a a square
transfer from
we can track that down with a crosswalk
we should be able to yes okay it looks
like i'm sorry sean no i
i apologize it's difficult um
one of the things that i had intended to
do uh in the last budget and that
did not happen when i became
commissioner and i started
looking around i found that we had
supplies
all over this place and we had way too
many things of
some things and uh it was just i said
no we have to stop this we need to have
all of our supplies centralized we can't
have
everybody duplicating everything because
in some areas
i think that makes sense we just ask you
because sometimes we don't see the
correlation
and we don't want to cut anything where
you've had a
an actual strategy for bettering the
running of your agency
what about class 27 we are not used to
seeing
transfers to doit go down so
dramatically
in fact we're used to seeing them go up
and nobody knows why so
to see them go down is wonderful well
we we replaced an awful lot of um
uh equipment this last year and as part
of the budget strategy we looked at
what did we really need to to replace
and so we're taking in to some degree a
gamble that um
we don't need to be replacing all of
these computers that were being
recommended so
we worked with doit and really looked at
what what our actual needs were and so
this was really
just we're not replacing as much
doesn't make a lot of sense to have new
computers and not have any people to
operate them so we opted to
take the gamble in that direction
people are chuckling here you can't hear
my computer is still not cooperating
with me i apologize
maybe that's one that we should have
replaced but
that may be the most important one after
all she's doing your
accounting all right i have switched
over to page 233 and i'm in
basically the division of weights and
measures because you see
unemployment compensation those kinds of
things are workers comp are given
figures given to you you live with them
you don't
schedule them we see again class 10
going up almost um
not quite a hundred thousand but close
to it ninety thousand
did you move people into division of
weights and measures
yeah the way that had been set up and it
didn't make any sense to me
product testing um
[Music]
fund a lot of weights and measures
people were funded through there but
they aren't the people who bring in the
income
so i realigned that so that
we were funding positions in regulatory
services with that instead of weights
and measures
so weights and measures uh personnel
were then funded
and you already mentioned you'd move
some of your equipment
and this is class 30 and new equipment
around to a more appropriate place so we
see that
in this weights and measures budget as
well
yes
representative leishman has a question
how are you sean well paul i'm well
represented how are you good thanks
so on page 234 i see a substantial
increase about 175
000. and it looks like you're adding
like two
new people to the weights and measures
group well
no that's that's the realignment
actually as i just said i really never
understood
why we were funding weights and measures
positions from
the other uh from the scale and product
testing fund
so we're just it came out
you know that we're we're using in total
i think more money out of that fund
but that did increase weights and
measures it was just a realignment
okay there's no new positions uh in this
budget at all
have you seen what the governor put in
hb2 for you
hope hopefully the language for
uh the integrated pest management is in
there we did request that and you'd
agreed that
but beyond that i haven't seen anything
okay we do have a draft copy so we have
seen it
the status of as i went to the governor
yesterday for final review
we're hoping it gets released to the
public
this afternoon because it is in march
and we are working on the budget so it's
kind of late
we will probably have to ask you to come
back for 10 or 15 minutes
to go over that you do have a new fund
in there
and of course we see the language but we
never see the rationale behind it or the
need or the business need or the
strategy you've come up with
to use that fund
commissioner
i know we're all a weight commissioner i
can see eyes but i see no no questions
and i see heads going no representative
waltz do you have a question
i do uh i don't mean to
talk over you um i just have a question
if you were to be level funded from the
prior biennium
um how much more would you require to be
level funded from the prior biennium
when we're talking um general fund
dollars
uh which for us is you know we're about
50. um our general fund dollars the
difference between
21 and 22 is 460 000
uh we would need additional funding in
and non-general fund dollars um
well when we when we do when everything
comes out in the wash
we're about a hundred just about two
hundred thousand dollars
short uh in 22
but only 27 000 short and 23.
commissioner wayne michelson
i'm sorry i'm trying to catch you okay
when michelle's computer
works will you just zip over to or have
her zip over to janet
and understanding what happened in class
110 i don't want to leave you
without enough money to pay for an
existing employee
and when you see just a four thousand
dollar difference
you start thinking do we get enough
money for the employee
or maybe you have somebody who's vacant
that you're going to hire after
the year starts i don't i don't know but
we'd like to
just double check that so that you are
not left
a little bit to it too as well um
currently i was
i was hired just this past
year and another employee was hired
so we were kind of at the low level of
the pay scales
so that's why it drops so the next pay
scale
it'll go up a little bit each year
um and we also do have a vacant position
um that we hopefully will be filling
soon okay so michelle if i let me make
sure i understand this because again my
concern is making sure we have enough
money to pay existing staff
and adjusted authorized 2020 with
one we have a hundred thousand
few dollars and in recommended 2022
we have 96 000 and a couple of dollars
so you you
think it's because we've had two staff
change and the pay scale's a little
lower than the people in 21 so you have
i believe so yes um i will definitely
verify
that and get back to with janet
please we want to be sure everybody gets
paid who's
in the budget representative patch you
have your hand up sir
um thank you madam chair just just when
the commissioner comes back
you addressed one concern i have the
other one is is will he be bringing back
a summary of the questions you asked uh
on each budget
well he basically told us he's added no
new full-time staff
no part-time staff he has moved people
around
um how many positions were eliminated
sean i didn't hear you say you're
eliminated but you reorganized
no i had he had just barely gotten back
up to full staffing i think we still had
one
vacancy in pesticides it's a
federally funded position but for the
first time
in anybody's memory we were finally back
up to uh full staffing when this
hit so uh good okay thank you
one of the questions we ask is is your
agency adequately staffed to complete
all work assigned to your agency in
state law
and the reason we ask that is because if
you get a performance review
and we have failed to staff you
appropriately you should not get a ding
on your ability to perform because the
legislature was unable
to provide you what you need we
we are we are not able to do everything
that we're
tasked with doing uh probably the two
divisions that are
are best able to perform all their tasks
are probably pesticides which of course
is
extremely important to make sure that we
are adequately adequately
regulating the use of pesticides in the
state
and plant industry
is i think um able to keep up with the
work
that they have and regulate those things
of course you know a big problem in this
state is in these
invasive species of plants and
insects and certainly um
plants are getting out of control when
you look at the bittersweet and you look
at the multiflora rose and
the knotweed and many things like that
but
you know we're not able to be as
aggressive there
where we're not doing as good a a job
weights and measures and we're well
we'll hopefully get back up to full
full staffing we need to do more
auditing in that area
um you know we're keeping up with the
licensure and working
hard there but do we get out there and
check the work that other people are
doing as
uh as much as we should know um
regulatory services
uh again we're keeping up with the
licensure and the registration of
products
but we're supposed to be actually doing
an analysis of many of those products
we're not able to do that with the staff
and never have been we're much better
off than we were
animal industry is the area that we're
in the worst shape really and that has a
lot to do with pet vending
laws were changed i made it very clear
we would be in complete failure
in that area my staff is working
extremely hard to do the best they can
um but you know we said we
needed at least four people to do what
was being asked
we were given one that's why we're
trying to get the database
and within that request which is a
separate bill there is an i.t
person for that um
in my office particularly i mean there
there are really three and a half of us
um and there really should be a
a real deputy commissioner here we can't
move forward with a lot of the things
that we should be that was something
that i was hoping to to request this
year but obviously with the pandemic and
everything else i
i chose not to but so the corollary to
that question
is if we cannot add the adequate
staffing
should we consider suspending a law for
the biennium
because you are not staffed to do it
but um because they're so correlated
we're
doing many other things there's not a
specific thing that i could say
take this away and it'll alleviate it
they're they're intertwined and where
there are just
parts of things that we're not able to
get done
in in some of those areas okay
so this was a question from vice
chairman emery
what things are you doing that are found
in state law
that could be eliminated and why if any
in terms of the the things we're charged
with doing i don't think there's
anything that we are doing that should
be eliminated
uh that has a budgetary impact i think
they're all important
things and i think we just need to
continue to work to see
how we can get to that level of
performance where we can do everything
the legislature
has asked us to do but you know when i
took over
former commissioner merrill referred to
what we do as
um triage to
it to some degree some areas that's
still true i think we are
in less triage mode than we used to be
except for animal industry and
particularly with the
pet vending that's a very very difficult
situation and frankly we're dealing with
some very very
difficult people and
so that's going to continue to be a real
but um okay we have two more questions
one of them was
discuss any hb2 sections obviously we
already talked about we'll have you back
to look at that
fund you have in there that will be i
don't know five or ten minute discussion
we'll probably put together
a roundtable and have several
commissioners with short sections come
be able to answer questions for us and
then the other one was what priorities
did you have that were not funded
what's the cost the description the
impact of not funding i think you've
spoken already
to the assistant commissioner situation
what else did you have
well the governor did approve all of our
prioritized needs and we
we went with a very lean um
ask if you will and um
so um you know the governor did
did address all of those and i didn't
ask for
for some other things that i would have
liked to because i recognize
the difficulty that we're going to have
in this budget cycle
um you know the one big ask that i that
he did
agree to we had funded uh in the last
biennium 750
000 for uh ag land development
which can be matched by federal funds
obviously
we weren't able to spend any of that
we've asked and
he has agreed for 250 000 in the second
biennium
which will bring us 250 000 of federal
funds
so that was our one big ask that is
there um the others are
relatively small like 4 000 a year
increases for ag in the classroom
and the ffa programs and
um some other minor
minor things but you know we didn't ask
for a lot
and the governor thankfully did
did that did give us what we asked for
in our prioritized needs
okay so that runs through representative
hatcher's question representative
leishman you have a question
uh thanks man of chair is your
microphone on yes it is
um so on page 271 or
our page 271 the other funds you
received in
the actual funds in 2020 were 1.4
million dollars
and in the governor's recommended budget
uh you're looking to receive 2.6
million dollars so about a 1.2 million
dollar increase
where are those other funds coming from
and
are you including any new fees or
increasing fees this year thanks no
and i i'm not my my numbers aren't quite
lining up but i'm looking at it
in 21 was other funds of
just over 2 million and then
2.6 some of that is a
you know i think a an ac a better
estimate of what those other funds for
those are all of our other fees
and and funds combined so the money that
comes in
that we keep for um the uh
scale and product testing fund that's a
fund that 50
goes to the state we keep 50
then we have the pet population control
that money
all goes out for spay and neutering
we have um the
the um pesticides the integrated
pesticide
fund that 75 goes to the state 25
comes comes there uh
and then all of our other licensing
through through
the divisions that's our our total
so i think some of this may have been um
we've done a better job of estimating
and of course things are
are going up and as we have more staff
we've actually been able to
to find a lot more people who should
have been registered and
licensed in very various areas that's a
huge problem when you're understaffed
there's a lot of people who just simply
are not complying
voluntarily with the law and we have to
uh to find them
a lot of products out there that are
being sold and
pet food a lot now is being sold over
the internet and we're
trying to figure out how to how to deal
with that that's something that
everybody's dealing with in every state
but um
all right thanks thanks madam chair
representative tubers
thank you madam chairman thank you um
for being here commissioner
i have a question there seems to be an
overlap or at least i need clarification
between
what your department is doing and the
university system and extension
is there any type of correlation or
cooperation or collaboration
well there is an awful lot and we have
an awful uh
say awful waffles awful is a terrible
word to use for this
but there is a lot of cooperation
i i refer to uh unh cooperative
extension really as our sister
organization
we're the regulatory branch they're the
educational branch
and of course that goes hand in hand
so there are contracts that we have with
cooperative extension
and we work very very closely with them
but
there's nothing that we do that they
also do and there's nothing
that we do that they also do so it's
really a glove in hand
i think you've answered all of our
questions thank you for doing that and i
thank michelle for looking up those
answers to some of those little
questions to make sure we have things
done correctly
and commissioner when we get down to hb2
we'll probably ask you to come back to
talk about that
new non-lapsing fund that is proposed
and the purpose
and what it's going to bring to us do
you have any questions for us
no i just i apologize for the breakdown
and communications i don't
hey it worked out well good it worked
out
we got everything done excellent thank
you for coming
okay
you have both of them thank you very
much
you're welcome welcome to division one
what page is the budget on is somebody
okay we're on budget book page 186 for
people in the audience who have a budget
book
i'm sorry madam chair i didn't get that
page number can you please repeat it
lindsay we'd like to turn it over to you
and let you get started talking to us
about your agency your work and your
budget
excellent thank you well good morning
madam chair members of the division for
the record i'm lindsay courtney
the executive director of the office of
professional lease insurance
certification
with me is oplc's business administrator
jason richard as well as
joseph shoemaker our division director i
apologize for not being able to be there
physically
with you today but we're all here to be
able to answer questions as needed
i certainly appreciate the opportunity
to testify before you today regarding
the governor's recommended budget for
so you'll see in your presentation
materials
basically some overview of the state
agency and i just wanted to highlight
this because i think it really
sets the stage for some of our budget
requests as reflected in the governor's
recommended budget
so as you know plc is the state agency
responsible for administering 54
boards councils and commissions in the
state of new hampshire
as well as currently the prescription
drug monitoring program or pdmp
it is a new agency and it is certainly a
small agency with only 64 permanent
classified positions at present
however the impact on the state of new
hampshire is vast in
in fiscal year 20 alone
oplc had 223 000 occupational licenses
that were active in new hampshire
under the agency and this figure
represents a 29
increase from fy 19 alone um it suffices
to say that
every person in the state of new
hampshire has interacted with this
agency or one of its licensees
it's important to know i think for
purposes of the budget of course
that oplc is a self-funded agency its
funding is restricted and must only be
used toward the cost of licensing and
enforcing the occupational licensing
regulations
under under on the practice acts
so we're all aware that the purpose of
the boards under it
oplc is to protect the public and
obviously the general court has
concluded that we need to ensure that an
individual meets minimum standards
necessary to practice a particular
profession
and we do that through occupational
licensing so when we think of it that
way occupational licensing
is um by its very nature a purposeful
barrier to workforce
and therefore it does play a vital role
in workforce and
impact in workforce on our community so
what is the agency's purpose
relative to the boards i would say that
oplc's purpose is a little bit different
our purpose is set forth in the statute
310a and it's really to promote
efficiency and economy in the
administration of these licensing boards
so our objective is to assist the boards
in protecting the public
while at the same time ensuring that
licensing is efficient
so as to reduce unnecessary workforce
barriers
and from my perspective the two major
barriers to workforce entry
in this state as it pertains to
licensing are the time it takes to
obtain a license
and the time it takes for someone to
re-enter the workforce after a complaint
has been filed
represented walls has a question for you
would you take it
absolutely
you're muted mary beth you're mute
you're muted i got it i i took a minute
um my question man i'm sure simply is uh
there's no documents either on the
lba website or in our email on this and
i'm wondering if the
documents are available to those of us
remote
it's the same answer as i gave you
earlier mr hoffman is here alone he's
working as fast as he can
mrs lavinas had an electric problem
and so they will come up thank you i
just
that's fair answer i just didn't know if
i was missing something thank you
please continue thank you so through the
governor's recommended fy 22 and 23
budget the agency
will strive to eliminate unnecessary
workforce barriers by
accomplishing two things significantly
reducing the time frame for licensure
and significantly reducing the time
i do want to highlight um some of the
things that oplc is currently
working toward that that really falls
into place with
um some of our budget requests for fy 22
and 23.
we've been actively working to achieve
those two goals by using our existing
resources but of course we need some
additional assistance with funding
one of our top projects has been our
agency reorganization and you'll see
that that's reflected
um and the governor's recommended budget
yes that's in hb2 as well so we do all
have a draft copy of hp2 so we've been
able to read that
so we are going to want to walk through
that reorganization to understand it
absolutely from a historical background
um
when oplc was created the boards and the
board staff were essentially just
um plopped into a structure that really
resembled
what the structure had been for the
various boards that came over to oplc
um their staffing remained the same
their policies remained
the same the procedures remained the
same everything remained the
same except for their location obviously
that's my perspective
um and i think for several years uh they
operated essentially in the same manner
as they did prior to
plc's creation about a year ago
um we started on this project to really
to do a deeper dive to to make sure that
we're meeting our statutory mission and
one of the things that we observed was
that
that agency structure was a barrier to
achieving
efficiencies many of our staff were
doing the same tasks
in many different ways in other words
you had
54 different ways of handling a
complaint you also had multiple people
touching complaints you had 54 different
ways of
processing a license and so we started
to develop
a project to reorganize the agency into
two divisions based on job function
again there are two primary purposes of
our agency which is to license
individuals and to conduct
investigations and so
we wanted to re to allocate our staff
based on those two
two primary functions um so we did um
we have started to move forward with
this through our physical relocation to
seven equal square which was
um not anticipated as i think you are
aware
um and so we started to move staff into
these functional
areas but the budget obviously is going
to formalize that process
so in july of 2020 um we began
reorganizing staff based on job function
in lieu of subject matter
boards and this has allowed us to really
take a deep look at what our procedures
and our policies and our rules are
regarding these two primary functions so
that we can be efficient we can't have
one way of
doing business instead of 54. we've also
centralized our male intake
to make sure that we're handling mail
and also monies
on the same way through our finance
office instead of
through our license clerks that was
completed in december of 2020
we are centralizing our customer service
instead of
individual license clerks i'm fielding
various questions
we've created or are creating a customer
service uh
group the go live date for that is
mid-march in 2021
and we're working on adopting you know
the same policies and procedures for all
boards concerning investigations and
licensing
we've also embarked on a mission to
leverage technology where appropriate
so um previously we
have always had the my license office
enterprise solution i think that
dates back many years um but it was
essentially a first come first serve
whichever staff member
wanted to go online you know they
contacted the two duit people who are
dedicated to this project and
they got in line regardless of the
impact on the state or workforce
um so we've taken that on and we've
developed a project plan
and all licensing renewals will be
online by march 15th of this year
all licensing initial applications
should be online by the end of fy22
we've completely redesigned our website
that
website goes uh live on thursday i'm
very excited about that
and we're working on scanning in all of
our documentation um that was really
necessitated by the move from field work
um so that we can move all of our
documentation online
and streamline the processes so that's
what we've been doing and it really can
i ask you a question about this
of course many of the licenses
require on the job training or
regular training classes or whatever i
know real estate licenses they have to
complete so many courses are they going
to be able now to submit that
electronically
yes yes we don't want to have any paper
in the office because it
it really increases the amount of time
to have to manually process that
information
in addition we don't have any storage
space
we've decreased our square footage
significantly
um so oplc3 the governor's recommended
budget proposes to continue to maximize
efficiencies and agency operations by
accomplishing several things
formally reorganizing the agency to
divide staff based on job function as i
noted
significantly reducing oplc's part-time
class 50 budget and utilizing those
funds to assist in
establishing full-time positions
historically oplc's
workforce about 20 has been part-time
and that's really been a barrier for
efficiencies it's difficult to find
part-time workers
um oftentimes people utilize part-time
positions as a stepping stone to
full-time employment elsewhere
and so we're constantly retraining and
it's it's just really not efficient or
productive
and then we'd also like to establish
oplc as 125
agency uh we have eliminated our double
accounting
method to increase transparency in our
finances
and we've moved all expenses to
administration you'll see in this budget
um mainly because uh with the
reorganization it's unclear
um where the expenses will kind of fall
between the two divisions
because we don't have that historical
data
finally technology you'll see class 27
has some you know
fairly large increases but our position
is that we need to make initial
investments in technology to greatly
increase efficiencies in licensing and
disciplinary actions and reduced
workforce barriers
and as an aside i'll give you um i'll
give you a tidbit of information
with emergency order 15 the agency had
to act really quickly in order to
adopt an emergency licensing process and
we were
um really anticipating that our
physicians and our nurses would be the
ones applying for these emergency
licenses to assist with copen 19.
what we observed was that the large very
large majority of those
initially applying for emergency
licenses were actually mental health
providers
many of whom live in new hampshire but
work elsewhere and when you talk to
these providers they do not
a lot of them don't work in new
hampshire mainly because
um they were able to obtain employment
in other states barriers uh
their border states um more quickly
um because we know vermont for example
will turn around license times in 24
hours in massachusetts it's also beating
us in that
so there there's really a need for us to
uh on a workforce and for us to reduce
so to accomplish all of our objectives
oplc proposes through the governor's
recommended budget to increase
its fiscal year 2223 budget
um mainly in several categories
uh class 10 obviously that includes 11
new
positions not including the mechanical
licensing board which is also slated to
come over to your plc
class 20. um that really is is
you'll see is a 200 000 increase but
it's it's mainly for credit card
processing fees as we move
everything online we will be taking in
more credit card payments
obviously and that 2.3 fee
um that is the average of credit card
fees
will eat up those costs our class 22
move to eagle square obviously our
increase in runs
where were you before you moved we were
at philbrook
right you're one of the philbrook people
just possible okay
so i did want to highlight two two key
components regarding the governor's
proposed budget
and i know that commissioner goulet is
presenting on class 27 but
um but class 27 is a key component of
um oplc's budget and how it's going to
basically move the agency forward and
achieving efficiencies
so in january 2020 oplc and doit
saw and obtained gnc approval to
establish an i.t manager and a business
analyst position within doit to be
embedded in the agency
and to permit oplc to accept and expend
funds for these positions
we were able to hire um this past fall
and i'll say that this has been a total
game changer for the agency um all of
the projects that i just mentioned
in terms of redesigning the website
redesigning a covid microsite
bringing all renewals online and
bringing all licensing online
all of that is through the work of these
two positions and
commissioner goulet's um incredible
support with his agency
and in order for us to continue our
projects we certainly need to
um to continue to fund these positions
we also have some additional prioritized
needs that were included in the
governor's recommended budget
we have the 400 000 initial fee for the
investigations and inspection software
right now all of our investigations are
done uh manually
with a paper process um same thing with
our inspections
you know our pharmacist will go out with
the paper
you know paper sheets as well as our
cosmetologists and draft-up
inspections and then we have to manually
upload them into our system that's
really inefficient
um and also it's not transparent for the
public we'd like to be able to post
those online
um we are in dire need of a document
management system
with our move to seven eagle square we
lost a significant amount of square
footage
and by virtue of the fact that we do not
have an agency-wide retention policy
something that we're trying to
fix with senate bill 58 we
essentially have to retain all these
paper documents
so we've been scanning them in and
working with
archives have been we are able to get
rid of our paper documents
but we need an actual way to store the
documents so that they're retrievable
and document management
will be a key part of that so are you
shipping your paper documents to
archives you said working with archives
so archives approved our policy that
allows us to
retain documents in electronic form um
and to get rid of the paper documents
okay that satisfies their retention but
we have not actually destroyed any paper
documents because we want to make sure
that we're consistent with our naming
conventions and have an actual
streamlined approach to storage at this
point so that they're retrievable
thank you you're welcome um so in terms
of class 10 one of the questions
that the division asked was what new
positions are contemplated in the
governor's proposed budget so within the
efficiency budget
we had again requested to significantly
decrease our class 50 budget
and increase our class 10 budget in the
efficiency budget we've requested six
positions
to include two hearing examiners an
administrator three
a program assistant are two program
assistants twos and an investigative
paralegal
additional prioritized needs includes
five positions and administrator three
two program assistant twos and
investigative paralegal
and program specialist four the
governor's
proposed budget also contemplates
transferring seven existing positions
from the department of safety to oplc
and transferring five
you know six positions from oplc to the
department of health and human services
for
the prescription drug monitoring program
talk about the safety transfer that's in
hiv too so we've all had an opportunity
to read that
you're acquiring a new board basically
aren't you
yes and how was that funded in safety
it's funded through uh license fees with
a mechanical licensing board
so they they're not spending
fewer general fund dollars for example
because these are
transferred to you is that correct
correct
and in you in your area they will be
funded by the same license fees yes yes
correct
and they had seven and you're taking all
seven
they had nine and in discussions with
the fire marshal
apparently two of those positions were
doing work
um essentially unrelated to
the inspections or the licensing for the
mechanical board i think they also do
some fireworks licensing um
tobacco some other things and they they
needed to
retain those two and so the positions
that are coming over are six inspectors
and a program assistant too
and what are you sending to hhs you're
sending the pdmp
yes and it's staff
did did you have six staff with that
so we have um let's see we have the
program
administrator one that's a um that's a
full-time permanent classified employee
then there's
um she has two
permanent classified employees and then
she recently obtained approval for
three on nine t's
that are funded directly by the cdc
grant
we're sub-guarantee of hhs
so those are temporary positions
she got some general funds last biennium
didn't she
there it's actually agency funds i think
she she previously received general
funds but the agency has paid for
mark's position and how will this
are you transferring funds to hhs
we're not transferring funds at the
moment to hhs we do have statutory
um uh we do have statutory authority to
send over licensing fees
to support hhs hhs are i'm sorry the
pdmp with the exception of one position
is um completely funded through grants
at the moment
okay thank you you're welcome
so in terms of whether our agency is
adequately staffed to complete all work
assigned under state law i would say
yes under the governor's proposed
recommended budget
um without the without the additional
personnel and i t support contemplated
there will be backlogs of licensing
leading to
workforce barriers and reduced workforce
availability in the state
um as i explained earlier um
vermont is really beating us uh in terms
of healthcare
workforce uh being able to turn over
licenses quickly
we've alleviated some of that by
granting the agency instead of the
boards the ability to
issue temporary licenses and we are
doing that in 24 business hours or less
um which has definitely helped um
but in order in order to really be
competitive in workforce we need
additional staff to support our
licensing and investigative efforts
i would say that oplc historically has
it has not
been sufficiently staffed much of our
workforce is part time
so we have that constant turning of
positions we also only have 17 licensed
clerks to manage nearly 230 active
230 000 active licensees
um as an as an example when the
emergency licensing process was created
i personally spent the better part of
two weeks manually licensing people
until about midnight at my kitchen table
and we just didn't have anybody to do it
um the average board administrator has
at least five boards to administer
and the boards traditionally meet
monthly and prior to some
reclassifications
that we did for personnel this fiscal
year we did not even have one attorney
prosecutor in the building
um cases were not being prosecuted or
investigated
when we moved over um to uh eagle square
and as part of our reorganization
project we found
many many many cases that um needed to
be
investigated and we're pretty much done
through the backlog
um but without additional resources it's
it's going to
um we're not going to be able to keep up
uh what things are we doing in state law
that could be eliminated
um i i would say i have a laundry list
of money this has been speaking for a
moment we've had an electrical glitch
okay we're going to be in recess we've
had an electrical glitch
give us five minutes to get scott in
here to
take care of this where the high wind
the electricity is going on and off so
right now
no one outside can hear no one in this
room
can hear the only reason you can hear me
is i have my surface
pro here so i'm hooked up to the network
separately so bear with us while we get
him in here
he's here already working madame
chair we uh can hear i can hear just
from the public is back
listening lindsay i appreciate your
willingness to suspend when you're on a
roll
but we are functioning again so let's
continue
thank you i appreciate it um so in terms
of the things that could be
um eliminated that are that we're
presently doing
um rather than list them all
i i attached our um copy of my testimony
in support of
the oplc's three major bills um
there's a lot of cleanup that needs to
take place among the practice acts
in order to uh you know basically allow
us to move forward with our efficiencies
one of which is senate bill 13 um
that clarifies that oplc has the
authority to adopt fees for all boards
councils and commissions
um presently boards have retained that
authority
and a lot of the practice acts and so
we're kind of at a standstill
in being able to make any modifications
regarding fees
um there are other things that we're
doing in state law or that we are
required to be doing in state law that
really is inefficient
um one being that requiring a court
stenographer to be present for all
hearings we
record all hearings and it's later
transcribed but a stunner was really not
necessary
um and then um you know
removing requirements that we provide a
roster of licensees for a fee
obviously rosters are required to be
produced under 91a
accepting private information and so um
that additional requirement that we keep
on uh a
you know separate roster on file is
really
does not make sense um and
you know there are certain reporting
requirements that we have under 332g
for title iii boards that don't fall
within our agencies so
there are some things that need to be
done and that's in senate bill
58 and then finally in senate bill um
i'm sorry 133 um
uh i'm sorry hold on one moment
yes this makes some changes regarding
our investigations and our rulemaking
authority regarding investigations which
is
needs to be clarified um versus the
board's
uh rule making authority over
investigations and so that's reflected
in
senate bill um 133
i'm happy at this point to go through
some line items or i'm happy to just
answer
questions what do you think would be
representative leishman has his hands up
so i believe it's on roughly page nine
of the
first handout you gave us and you asked
for at least 11 new positions and of
course the transfer of seven
so do you have a cost to those uh
new positions the 11 plus will there be
any revenue generated from those
positions i would assume
perhaps some additional revenue through
enforcement or
other actions do you have anything that
you could give us on that
yes so the um
we can add up the cost for you um i
think it's roughly
the cost is set forth in the letter in
terms of salary benefits the full cost
of each position
we do have existing revenue um so oplc
at present um is taking in
i think this year we're anticipated to
take in about
13 million dollars next year i'm
projecting about
14 million dollars that's pretty
conservative with the addition of the
mechanical licensing board and the fact
that our license
at the number of licenses have continued
to increase
um so we are certainly able to fund
these additional positions particularly
given the fact that our class 40
our class 50 budget is anticipated to
decrease
about 400 000 um
and so this would just mean obviously
that the lapse to the general fund is
is less than what it presently is but we
do you have a follow-up yes
are there other questions at this moment
uh representative hatch is that your
hand up
that is madam chair thank you yeah just
just uh uh we started a conversation
about
uh your training classes and we added an
additional one
to help with rules and and i was just
wondering if that was adequate there
still seems to be some
um improvement needed and and if you
could just speak to that or do
or do you have an additional need or
what's going on there you may
yeah i would say we still have a backlog
we're trying to work our way through the
backlog as you know
oplc does about 20 percent of the
state's rulemaking
um and prior to you adding on that
additional position
we had one attorney who provides all of
our general legal counsel to the agency
the 54 boards councils and commissions
does all the rulemaking and now is our
legislative liaison
so it's a lot of work obviously and it
has created a backlog
um unfortunately we were kind of into
catch-22 in terms of what to do with
that additional uh attorney position
without having a prosecutor in-house um
we were not able to prosecute or
investigate
a lot of cases um and so in terms of
meeting our statutory obligations i made
the decision that i thought that a
backlog on rules was a little bit better
than having
uh no prosecutions or investigations so
we've reclassified that
extra that additional attorney position
to
an administrative prosecutor position so
that we can at least prosecute cases
we also reclassified um
another position though to add on a
program specialist for position
to assist tom broderick with role making
and he and tina kelly are working
through the backlog
as quickly as they can um and she she's
great at being able to provide that
role-making support
i think what's lacking though is is an
attorney to be able to provide
that legal support to the boards um that
obviously team is not able to provide
so so if i may not have a chair just
just to explore this
i'm not sure i'm not hearing that
there's not a need for another position
just just to uh point out that
um rule making may seem less important
than hearings but understand you you
have a plethora of rules expired
and you know what happens when they're
expired they're not enforceable
and it could be a very serious problem
for the state
as well as a licensing board ad
infinitum
so is there a still a need for another
position because that
that concern certainly needs to be
addressed it really does
thank you madam chair i agree with you
representative hatch and what we had
recommended
um in the agency submission is and
we we recommended one hearings examiner
position
and one attorney position and the
governor's recommended budget contains
um no attorney positions and two
hearings examiner positions
our recommendation obviously you know we
support the governor's recommendation
but from an agency need we certainly do
need another attorney position
because i agree with your assessment
lindsey could we turn to page 195
and since you've done such a massive
reorganization which i understand why
you've done it and i applaud you for
bringing
more efficiency page 195 in the budget
does present a summary of your agency so
without trying to look at accounting
unit to accounting unit
why is this zero why is that down why
don't we look at this summary and why
don't you walk us through
starting with federal funds all the way
down through the total number of
positions
and talk to us about this page
absolutely let me just pull up so i make
sure that i'm looking at the right
because i
i was working off of um our condensed
195.
i'm not sure i'm on the right page jason
do you know what
it would be the last page of the
budget
and that was page 195. in our budget
books
lindsay and we we have the printed
budget books so
we have one version i know you guys have
gone through
several iterations with the governor yes
we just have what came out okay
um so i gave you our page number because
that's what we have so i have at the top
i have you know the administration
class 10 that's what i'm looking at is
that what you're looking at
no the last page starts with zero one
general government
expenditure total for general government
federal fund funding general funds
other funds then we get down to net
total funds
number of positions permanent classified
unclassified total number of positions
okay the actual very summary page
got it um i apologize
no problem so much
we're glad we haven't gone through three
oh here we go
[Music]
he's muted yeah
yeah let me pull it up and i'll email
you a copy thank you
i just want to make sure i'm looking at
or jason can run us through it i i don't
care i just
since there's been such a difference in
absolutely
and then chairman while we're waiting
may i ask a question
yes so i'm trying to understand uh
lindsay do you receive general funds or
are you fully self-funded
we are fully self-funded we do not
receive any general funds
so to that end in your presentation
which i eventually found you mentioned
that it's going to cause delays i think
it's on page 10 of your presentation
um delays if you don't have more staff
it sounds like you need legal staff and
i.t staff
and so if we were to
give you the funding for that staff out
of your own revenues
how much would you need
um i think it amounts to
so not accounting for pdmp
and non-accounting for um mechanical
licensing
we would need in fiscal year 22
11 0.9 million dollars
in fiscal year 23 12.2 million
if we added in the appropriations for
mechanical licensing there was um
class 10 and class 60 i believe we'd
need
12.6 and fiscal year 22
and 12.9 in fiscal year 2023
and again i'm still projecting um just
based on our current fees
um a projected revenue of about 14
million dollars
and we have that on page 194 for people
who are
so if i may follow up with those numbers
how how what's the difference between
those numbers and the amount of money
you're actually getting are you saying
it's like 12.6
additional money and 12.9 additional
money
no um it ends up being so
so it ends up being about a difference
of 1.5 million dollars
in fiscal year 20 2022 and about
1.7 million dollars in fiscal year 2023
compared to the adjusted authorization
for fiscal year 2021.
so um to put it this way so we lapsed
um last year we lapsed about 3.2 million
dollars to the general fund our last
target this year is 3.6
so that would effectively reduce our
laps by a million and a half or 1.7
million dollars across
you know each fiscal year 22 and 23.
thank you so i have it up here um
lindsay you had a net increase of 18
people
you lost pdmp you gained you reorganized
and you added some new people
of course that being said we are
reducing our class 50 so right now our
we actually have more bodies in the
building than the 66
that are reflected in terms absolutely
class 50 doesn't show
in the uh because they're part-time
and the permanent one so i was looking
at your permanent new
full-time positions with the loss
with the new with the transfer out of
safety
which is in hb2 you went up
18. 18. and they don't they
um das who does the budgets for us does
not total up
the number of part-time people right
right how many new part-time people do
did you have
how many new we don't have any new
part-time positions we would have to
convert
we we will have to effectively eliminate
um positions i think right now
joe how many do you think we have i
think we have about
13 to 15 part-time positions at the
moment
at any given time it's about 20 percent
yeah correct i think last time i looked
it was 15 and it's always been
approximately 20
and what do they do for you
they fill major functions um so right
now our administrator three who's in
charge of all of licensing
is part time he's you know retiring in
june and one of the positions that we've
suggested be created as an administrator
so that we can have a full-time
supervisor overseeing licensing
we have one part-time investigator
and then we have a number of part-time
license clerks and
last biennium
there was a performance audit of the
real estate board
that had significant number of findings
that needed to be
addressed as part of your reorg
how are you handling some of those
deficiencies
and did you have did the mix of staff
you got
we see that so let me pull up the actual
notes from the findings because i don't
i would say that the personnel that have
been proposed are intended to address
issues that have been long-standing in
the agency regarding performance
so um yes so we had several
recommendations to the agency regarding
the real estate audit one was
improved supervision number licensing
activities um the recommendation
to oplc is to update and formalize
licensing policies and procedure
procedures um we're presently doing that
right now is updating all policies and
procedures through our reorganization
we're trying to standardize policies and
procedures regarding how we
options but certainly having an
administrator in a full-time position
overseeing all of that
is going to help you know um meet our
our requirements or performance
requirements under the audit
so this budget has that administrator
and we'll help you in that area
correct correct
um recommendations for improving fiscal
management
um the recommendation related to our plc
was to improve fiscal management
responsibilities by developing a cost
allocation method more reflective of the
cost to operate each cord
i would tell you that the cost
allocation method that plc has
historically used is one based on
revenue
we are that's not obviously the best way
to be doing that
we're moving to a cost allocation method
based on the number of licensees
as we consolidate and as we move forward
with
our reorganization the shared costs are
going up
and the direct costs that are trivial to
each board are going significantly down
um so sharing those shared costs based
on the number of licensing i think is
going to be a more accurate reflection
of the actual cost
um to each individual licensee and
review administrative rules um with the
support of oplc improvements rules and
adoption of rules i think this goes back
to our conversation
earlier with representative hatch
obviously oplc
had requested an additional attorney
that i think would assist with
role-making support
um and um i think certainly that
additional position
in lieu of one of our hearing examiner's
positions would assist with that
um the observation to improve records
management
develop procedures to implement policies
and facilitate the development of
records management program this goes to
our class
27 request specifically a document
management
system so that records are easily um
you know retained and are easily
retrievable in accordance with a
retention policy
we also have um senate bill 58 i believe
um would grant or feel see the authority
to adapt
to adopt a retention policy across the
agency one of the issues that we run
into
is the fact that all of these boards
have varying retention policies or none
at all so then we fall back on the
state's um regular retention policy
makes it very difficult for us to
actually manage files
and keep track of what files can be
destroyed and must be destroyed and
which files must be retained
and one of the things we need to do is
make sure that we're being consistent
in how we approach the same types of
trials
um further clarify and document uh real
estate commission
or plc rules and responsibilities um
this is
certainly ongoing through our
reorganization i think um
i think i think also this legislative
session i'm
hoping will help clarify the difference
in the two
roles i think that there is not yet a
consensus
in the state about what the purpose of
april plc is versus the boards
and certainly the reorganization and
having streamlined policies and
procedures
are going to assist with better defining
those goals and establishing a
performance measurement system that's
something that we're working with
um now as as we develop our strategic
planning
um going forward so i think the budget
does accurately reflect or it does
intend to address
all of the findings in the real estate
audit but the other audits as well
which are primarily related to you know
providing the
the appropriate administrative support
to the boards
i have one last question for you as i
understand what i read in hb2
about the oplc which was a long section
and listening to you today
if you do not get the section in the
sections in
hb2 related to oplc
you basically can't
manage the budget you've presented here
either they're
tied together as i think i understand
what i read and what you said is that
any other questions from any board
member
representative leishman uh thank you
madam chair and
good presentation but i do have a
oplc position crosswalk it's one of the
documents that we were given
and on i think it's page
four it lists the
uh executive director of oplc
twice and there's two salary lines one
for a hundred and seventy nine thousand
and
for a 194 000 and i didn't see
too many uh comparisons where jobs were
listed twice
for the same position especially like
for the executive director twice
do you see that on it's page page four
it's positions three and four in that
document
from the top down let me
pull it up it's the last page of your
crosswalk
in the org chart you presented it looks
like you have an executive director over
division of health health professionals
technical professions and
admin plus a second executive director
over
division of licensing enforcement and
admin
do you have yes positions no there's one
position and what this represents is the
the total cost for fiscal year 22 with
salary and benefits
is 179 000 approximately and the
total cost for fiscal year 23 it goes up
obviously with the increase um increase
and there's an increase in salary and
presumably benefits as well
yes okay because there was no indication
on here
i thought maybe that was it but it
didn't say so
curious
our those are the items in our budget
starting with the
i finally have the page the right page
that
that i was supposed to be on if that
sure okay but you need to give us the
page yeah so i think you were on
one one last page we looked at was 194
when we were looking at the addition of
madam chair this is mike i believe the
page that
oplc starts on is 180 186
and yes mike that's true by 200 we're in
another agency
okay
so i'm at the top general government
professional licensure and certification
okay 2404 is on page 186
okay so class 10
obviously there's an increase basically
between 463 000
in fiscal year 21 and fiscally your 22
year goes up to
573 thousand that's when the addition of
one position reflected it's the hearing
examiner
position reflected um and the governor's
proposed recommended budget
with class 11 um there was an increase
basically the fiscal year 20 in fiscal
year 21
did not contemplate um my position
starting off on the
the step that i did and so 22 and 23
represent
um purpose salary increases for our one
unclassified position
in administration which is the executive
director position
class 20 current expenses
sheet
okay
so the you know we have approximately 75
000 in supplies
which is consistent with what um fy 20
was which was 16
about 69 000 um
we have the largest expense is credit
card processing services
in fy 2020 it was approximately 150 000
in the governor's recommended budget and
we estimated about 300 000
for credit card processing fees based on
on the number of
credit card transactions that we we
anticipate
um capturing um through our online
licensing
um that also includes about about
hundred thousand dollars in postage
which is consistent with what we spent
in fra 2020 which is 97
000 um and a couple of other
smaller line items um class 22 is new
it's fairly new for us this year at
least in the large amounts
um previously i think we had some
storage expenses in class 20 and class
21 or i'm sorry in fiscal year 20 fiscal
year 21.
we did have to physically relocate um
to a non-state building back in july and
393 000 is our anticipated cost
for rents to leases other than states
organizational dues you'll see that
class 26
um previously had zero but that
that is just um for administration only
across the agency we actually
had um spent sixty two thousand three
hundred and fourteen dollars in fiscal
year twenty
and were authorized to spend eighty two
thousand two hundred and ninety two
um and so we've moved all expenses over
to administration
and so the fy 2022 and fy 2023 really
line up with our adjusted authorization
for 21
and that it's 87 000
um our organizational dues are
historically statutorily required for us
to participate in oftentimes our
organizations
um like national council for state
boards of nursing or the real estate
organization provide a vital examination
or exams or that sort of activity for us
so we're
historically required to participate in
them um as a matter of statute
so class 27 is um that's
that is a large increase transfers to
oit
um 473 000 in fiscal year 2020
we're up um additional authorization in
718 but obviously the governor's
recommended budget includes
a recommended appropriation of 1.2
million dollars and fiscal year 22 and
won
um 1 million 66 000
in fiscal year um 2023
and that really um the breakdown is
based on shared costs from doit
as well as upgrades as well as the cost
of our two it consultants
um additionally and i know commissioner
belay has gone over this
our board members do not have um
state-issued email addresses which
really poses a problem from a 91a
standpoint
um and so they've made some
recommendations for technology for that
and then finally our additional
prioritized needs regarding the
inspection software and the
investigation software and the document
management system so that's
essentially a one-time initial fee in
fiscal year 22 and 23.
transfers to general services class 28
although this states that an admin
um it was 25 000
if we're going on agency-wide we really
spent in fiscal year 2020 267
000 um and then fiscal year 2021 we were
authorized
264 000 this um was our rent for the
philbrook building
which was um owned by owned by the state
but obviously we paid a das
we have um the governor has recommended
that we
have an appropriation of about forty
three hundred dollars we are still
renting some storage space
in the walker building so that's
intended to capture that
our class 30. so
this shows that we previously had zero
dollars in admin
we did have about 12 000 that we spent
in 2020
in other divisions and that 17 000
is authorized in 2021 this is really for
vehicle replacement we have a number of
vehicles
um for inspectors that are about ready
to
die and need to be replaced and so
that's
um where that 50 000 uh comes into play
our class 38 technology and software
um so generally
so so that's intended to allow us to
have adobe pro software
so in fiscal year 2020 we spent about
twenty two hundred dollars in that
um we are authorized eleven thousand
dollars i'm not sure why
why this significant jump on fiscal year
we've estimated that we need another
three thousand dollars to keep renewing
that subscription of adobe pro
which in this electronic age is really
necessary for us to be able to edit
documents
um class 39 telecommunications
for admin in 2020 obviously we spent 4
agency-wide we spent about 51 thousand
dollars
in fiscal year 2021 for admin we were
forty authorized hundred dollars but we
are agency wide authorized
fifty three thousand four hundred and
eighty four dollars so
the increase is really just intended to
capture additional positions
and obviously the increase in cost so
we've estimated sixty four thousand five
hundred dollars for
telecom across 22 and 23.
our indirect costs um interestingly
so this previously captured both our
self billing as well as cap starting in
22 and 23. it's only going to capture
spy cap and not
self-filling so um class 40
for um admin 181
000. um it actually was significantly
more than that
when we look at agency-wide class 40 was
agency-wide class 40 was 2 million 471
in um in fiscal year uh 20
and in fiscal year 2021
4 million four hundred and forty three
thousand dollars but
again that includes our self billing so
one of the other reasons why we want to
do away with the self billing
is that it's not transparent and how
much you're actually spending
so obviously the recommended or what
they've estimated our supply cap to be
for
fiscal year 22 and 23 is you know 1
million 131
000 class 46 is our
consultant again it shows that we didn't
um have any
uh payments out of this and
administration but
agency-wide and fiscal year 20 we had 51
580. in fiscal year 21 we're authorized
452 um we're statutorily required to
contract the physician investigator for
the board of
medicine mainly and at present
that cost us 55 000 annually
we also have a contract with a dental
hygienist um to conduct inspection
inspections and investigations when uh
needed
and that contract is not anticipated to
exceed ten thousand dollars so that's
intended to capture
that um class 49 transfers to other
state agencies
this would really be our doj support our
department of justice support
so while we didn't have any allocated or
spent any in administration in fiscal
year 20.
we did agency-wide 678 thousand dollars
in fiscal year 2021 we are appropriated
690 000
and these numbers for 2022 and 2023 i
believe are based on
doj's our recommendations
class 50 you'll see um that
uh our our temporary um our class 50
positions in fy 2020 and admin we had 31
000 but agency-wide we had approximately
520 000.
um in fy 2021 we had
agency-wide 453 000
appropriated and um
we are anticipating to significantly
reduce that
agency-wide um to
156 000 in fiscal year 2022
and 162 thousand dollars in fiscal year
2023.
um class 57 um
in admin we we didn't have any money um
any funding spent out of this in
administration but we did
spend about two thousand dollars in
fiscal year 2020
and we had 3 000 appropriated in fiscal
year 21.
this is really where required um our
electricians our electrical inspectors
are required to keep
um inspection manuals so they have the
update
updated code so we need a small amount
of appropriations to make sure that we
have access to those materials
um obviously class 60 benefits class 61
62 we don't control that 64. 65 are
board expenses
so we did not pay any board expenses out
of
class 65 in administration and in 20 or
however we are moving all expenses to or
proposing to move all expenses to
administration
so in fiscal year 2020 we had we spent
134 000
at a class 65 um across the agency
and 144 000 is authorized in 2021
we are proposing an increase as
recommended through the governor's
budget to 208 000
and this really captures our per diem
for our board members
one of the issues that we're trying to
address in legislation this year
is to allow oplc to adapt or to
promulgate rules regarding perdiems
across all boards
right now the majority of health boards
the large majority of health boards
receive a per diem but it it varies
between
five dollars and hundred dollars it also
varies depending you know certain amount
of work needs to be performed that
varies
the majority of our technical boards do
not receive a per game so we want to
make sure that we're being consistent
and
and the work that's being performed and
also so that oplc can effectively budget
we do have issues right now with you
know um
to project how much we're going to be
spending in per diems
particularly for those boards that
receive payment for any work perform
that's board related it's hard to
it's hard to know um how much you're
going to spend
so we are projecting a slight increase
for that
class 70 and state travel reimbursement
um
obviously for fiscal year 20 we spent
in um admin but agency-wide we spent 70
439 uh dollars and fiscal year
2021 where i raised 124 275
agency-wide and um agency-wide we are
projecting um through the governor's
recommended
budget uh a need for 47 thousand dollars
for fiscal year 22 and 23.
class 27 really goes to our
mileage reimbursements for our board
members that we're statutorily required
to provide
we are anticipating a decrease um in
22 and 23 uh assuming that
um some continuation of remote meetings
is possible
but obviously if it's not possible um
those
those numbers may need to be adjusted um
um in terms of out-of-state travel we
have very limited out-of-state travel
all of our out-of-state travel
is paid by the various
conferences that we have to attend
through the professional association
so um ncsbn for example the national
council of state boards of nursing
will pay for a board member and or staff
member to go to their annual meeting
um and um so our
so sometimes our staff members and our
board members attend out-of-state
for out-of-state travel um i don't
anticipate any of that
this year um because all of our meetings
are being held
virtually but perhaps in fiscal year 20
and fiscal year 2023
um we are eliminating our class 89
transfers to the as maintenance fund
because we're no longer
being maintained by eas and
uh 531 i'll skip over 211 because that
has to do with our property and casualty
insurance
um 531 has to do with our professionals
health program
which we contract with new hampshire php
in order to
provide these services in terms of
monitoring and
um for our for 13 of our boards
as part of the contract though we are
able to add on additional boards and a
cost of eight dollars per licensee
you know plc is effectively able to
prompt we're seeking
or seeking legislation to allow us to
congregate rules
um to adopt fees uh to
to to basically um
get the cost of that um covered by
licensing fees
um we'd like as many boards to be able
to participate in this php program as
possible
but we are anticipating that um the 13
boards will remain at least work fiscal
year 2022
um so moving on um to the next page our
occ license review and uh reform
that was our um project we were funded
we received grant funds through the
department of labor we contracted with
a clear council of licensing and
enforcement and regulation
to provide an analysis regarding certain
entry-level
professions as well as
the office of professional licensure and
we did have a part-time physician funded
that
we have eliminated and we don't expect
um
that grant work will be completed by
sometime in april of this year
so um there's no so we will be
so um in terms of the expenditure total
for division of administration
you'll see that we had um fiscal year
2.2 uh 2 million 216 thousand dollars
fiscal year 2021. 3 million 460 thousand
dollars
that's increased to 6 million 436 000.22
and 6 million 370 thousand dollars but
that again
that is um basically putting all of our
expenses agency expenses into a division
of administration
with the exception of class um 10 class
50 and i think class
60. so we will have
um we currently have nine positions in
the division of administration and under
the governor's recommended budget we
will have
um 11 positions in
the administration we can move on
to technical although technical is being
eliminated
um i actually have three pages of xero
and that's due to your reorganization
right
that's great excuse me one moment madam
chair i have to plug in my computer
because
he's about to die should have done this
you gotta love technology
yeah much rather be in person
so we're proposing to eliminate the
division of technical professions
and then we're proposing um to eliminate
the division of health professions
and then we are proposing to create um
the division of licensing and board
administration
so that we can continue to streamline
all of our licensing functions
and you'll see in this division that um
the only classes that we have
are class 10 18 and 50.
and so 10 obviously class 10 has to do
with our permanent um classified
employees
and you'll see that those employees are
supported in their crosswalk
but primarily our licensing folks and
our board administrators
um we are not projecting much over time
but the
2010 that we are projecting was a
carryover
from um i believe it was the division of
health professions that's what we've
historically had
um allocated to us or appropriated in
terms of overtime
um often often our inspectors will be
called on
to to receive overtime because
inspections can sometimes last longer
than one anticipates
um so we've we've left that in there and
our class 50 is obviously significantly
reduced
to 64 000 um and 66 000
in the governor's recommended 22 and 23
budget
we are projecting 40 permanent
classified positions
as well as class 60 benefits 1.1 million
dollars and 1.2 million dollars
so um then the next division that we're
creating or proposing to create is the
division of enforcement
and again this includes class 10 1850
and 60.
um and then class 10 we have 1.9 million
dollars or almost 2 million dollars and
and fiscal year 23 2 million 100
116 000. we do have more overtime um
allocated in this
budget again this goes to our inspectors
particularly with the
addition of the six inspectors for
mechanical licensing
um we don't always use it but sometimes
our inspectors have to
work overtime with some of the
inspections that they're doing and
investigations
and then again our class 50 is
significantly reduced to 68 000
um in fiscal year 22 and uh 71 000 in
fiscal year
uh 23 and then of course our benefits
and we are anticipating 32 um
positions and this enforcement unit
enforcement division under the
governor's recommended
budget does anybody have any questions
on
on that how do your boards feel with
this reorganization
are they in favor i think
um i i think the majority are at this
point
um i think that the boards have been um
hesitant
to be uh accepting initially because
we've had so many issues with the agency
as you're aware
and um you know they wanted to make sure
that this was actually going to benefit
them
um but we've started we've certainly
been working with them
particularly with providing enforcement
support and they are
um really on board with that in really
um
supportive of those directions that they
haven't previously had that support
joe do you have anything that you'd like
to add because you have a lot of
interaction with the boards as well
well i think you captured it well um
the you know i think the board's
concerns
are you know that there's an open they
call it an
overreach if you will um and and we
clarify to them that we're not taking
the scope of practice from them
um but you know people get the two
intertwined sometimes
so um the boards that you know have
expressed concerns
that's what it's around and we quickly
come back to them and explain that
you know we're not trying to get into
your scope of practice at all
but there's no question when you say the
majority you know out of the 50
you know plus boards you know you're
talking a handful that really
have expressed concerns high high 40s
are
completely on board in my opinion
so representative leishman has a
question
so on one of another one of your
handouts that i was looking at the
crossbar versus the new accounting
units yes
there's a line as far as credit card
processing fees
which shows a fairly steep increase do
you
charge people when they use their credit
cards like the secretary of state
charges a small fee
to cover the cost versus the state
having to pay the cost
that's a very good question we don't
presently charge but we do
have a proposed rule um in the works
and we did file an initial proposal so
that we could
um shift the cost we do have that
authority under state law there's a
statute that allows us to do that
um and that is our proposal that we
would charge
because of technology it's a little bit
difficult to do so but our proposal
right now is to charge an additional
2.50
to assist with covering the cost of the
credit card fees
but obviously depending on the fee that
250 may not be 2.3
um and and i don't know where that rule
will go
um but our goal would be to to try to
shift that back on the licensee to some
extent
so that the state is not paying the cost
and one further question
follow-up chair also on that same page
uh rent to owners of non-state
facilities or buildings presently is
zero and you're going up
to 367 thousand dollars is
you couldn't find anything with das
no available state space no
i we got a call in june um
i got a call in june first essentially
from um
jane millerick saying we needed to move
july 1 because hhs needed our building
and um there was no state spanx
available for an agency of our size and
there were four agencies in that
building and i think they were able to
find state space for
others um but not for us okay
thanks madam chair representative
wallace you have a question
i do thank you madam chairman um i want
to go back to the topic we were
discussing before
representative lee simmons questions and
that is
at the time dois was created
i was hearing concerns from the staff
not from the boards but from the staff
to the boards that by centralizing this
and centralizing the personnel
that they would not have the same
expertise as each board's personnel
individually had so you know the
plumbing board they knew plumbing the
nursing board they knew nursing whatever
and when you have
a person handling multiple boards they
don't necessarily have the same
expertise in all those fields
and i'm wondering if you're hearing
i we're not hearing those concerns at
the moment from staff uh
what our staff are expressing is that we
are not we don't have sufficient number
of
individuals to assist and that's one of
the reasons why we proposed adding on
four additional board administrators i
know that historically the staff
have um you know when the staff came on
board they didn't necessarily come on
willingly when the boards came on board
they didn't really come in willingly i i
think that's
um and so i a lot of our staff were
really tied into their boards and and
that was great but we had to work
through some of those issues
from our perspective you don't
necessarily need to know
the profession that's why we rely on the
board members but the process should be
very
similar um certainly it's helpful if you
understand medicine but you don't need
to be a doctor in order to assist the
board of medicine and the same is true
for
dental examiners and by making the
processes the same
and efficient we should be able to
effectively provide that support to more
than one board that said we do need
additional support in order to be able
to do that
i don't see any other questions do we
have any questions
i have one manager here just a comment
patch
thank you madam jerry sorry to ask um
just as a note lindsay i just want to
thank you for your presentation
and and just from my perspective the
board has been
um the administration of the board has
been a concern in the past
but i i think there's a lot of
improvement that has taken place and i
think it comes from the top and i just
want to thank you
that's all thank you madam chair thank
you representative i appreciate that
i think it's like any other situation it
takes a while this
originally was an idea that governor
then governor hassan had that put things
together
and i think we're finally seeing the
fruition
of some of those synergies that she
hoped to see
and it just takes a while to get
everything to jail and it looks like
things are moving along
yes i i will say that the energy in the
building from our stack is very positive
we've done a complete 180 people are
excited about what we're doing
and we're really excited about being
able to move this
agency in a positive direction and i
really think in five years
new hampshire can be on the cutting edge
of occupational licensing
and looking at other opportunities and
ways that we can you know bring people
in
and make sure that we're adequately
protecting the public
but also thinking outside the box you
know looking at veterans and how we
how we you know bring bring them into
the state and
lindsey i really like to thank you
because we looked at
hb2 in that lengthy
situation with oplc you've pulled it
together very
nicely for us as how hb1 and hb2
tie together so i appreciate the time
you took making that very clear for us
and i appreciate you and your staff
being with us this morning
thank you for coming oh thank you for
having us pleasure thank you so much
the division is going to be in recess
until one o'clock
so i suggest we all
turn off our pictures i believe it's
what is known as
lunchtime uh
representative over this is mike can you
[Music]
yes